what do they call you jack fella or
black hat
man the black house man in the flesh
same [ __ ] different bankroll you want
to interview both of them and gonna cost
you twice as much
black f man in hollywood appreciate the
time
you bring me out you know what i'm
talking about hit a true story
everybody want to know people don't know
just come on in
i got you yeah but dog you doing like
he's just a cool [ __ ] the black half
man you have to
the black half is a different negro man
that's what i'm trying to tell you he's
something
he's something way unique man i got man
i got little kids wanting to be the
black half
you believe that you're right my biggest
peer pressure is the church
is that right the chairman as i call him
the bishop
his my biggest peer pressure he's 70
years old almost
peer pressure supposed to be around you
amongst the age of your peers
you're my biggest peer pressure so long
story short
i don't even i hadn't even smoked when i
came out here
i've been quit smoking but getting with
the church
this is cali he smoke everywhere he go
everywhere we go it don't matter before
when they weren't even legal in other
states he wants to can cali go to other
states
and be smoking in the club right in
there and people have to throw us out
and he'd be like okay come on let's go
it ain't man yeah how long you're on the
bishop
oh the church is my god we've been
together for we've been together
since um at least around around two
thousand two thousand two thousand
one so you're from flint michigan
originally born and raised
and when did you get start started with
uh
five well i once got introduced to the
game around maybe
was it 99 by about 2 000. almost 2 000.
so about 99 2 000. how did you get
introduced to that
um i was on the search to find
just to find what was available out
there in the world to me i knew it was
something more than was in flint
you know just the dope dylan you know
just the hustling basically
back then you know mainly crack weed you
know little things
you know that became bigger but in time
i just knew it was something else out
there in the world that a better
opportunity so i went out there looking
for it and once i got to memphis
i actually had to stay there on accident
but when i stayed
on an accident a little longer than i
really expected when i first went there
i acquired the information from the guy
that uh a guy that was actually in the
business and knew
you know had a different route than i
had previously seen i had never seen
this wrong i thought he
always seemed like he had money but i
never knew what he really did i thought
he was selling drugs like
every other person ever come out of
flint so but long story short he had a
whole different thing set up
and he was dealing with you know with
the strip clubs and um
he was having a life of a guy that was a
kingpin
and so to me from the outside looking in
or even bigger actually
so um long story short he acquired you
know i acquired the information through
him to
find out how to do what he was doing as
he was telling me i wasn't taking it
serious
but once i um uh
well this is what happened true story
my man had uh he had uh
been giving me the information about the
business for a while and i was in town
maybe about maybe a week and a half
two weeks you know after i originally
planned on staying he had a good friend
of mine that was there as well beside
this guy but they both were from flint
but this guy was like i said living a
life that was unbelievable
so um
once he had been telling me about you
know i could get girls and girls to like
me and i could do it
um i just was you know procrastinating
because i really want you know i
had my mind hurt on other things at this
time you know i really wasn't passionate
about it but
i just seen what he was having from it
and that was you know something admired
alone
so once i um once he uh we got together
one day and i was trying to buy some
weed
and i i didn't have the money on me at
the time to buy the ounce i wanted
so i was telling him let me borrow some
money but i have money put up you know
somewhere but the people where my money
was that would happen to be out of town
and he knew that he so it was no problem
but i told him i said man let me borrow
some money you know i need about 200 to
buy this ounce
he said man and he said this one thing
he said that's what i'm saying about you
[ __ ]
he said y'all he said now you know you i
didn't told you how to the game and what
you can do to get money with the girls
and you still want to talk about you
borrow he said you would have been got
that girl that said you can get down
here
you would have been made that money and
more money been able to buy as many
ounces as you want so when he said the
one word you [ __ ]
it was like something triggered in me
like he thought i was like a different
you know like like a weaker i don't know
what he thought but i guess he thought i
was a weaker version of whatever his
version was when he said you [ __ ] and
that just stuck
you know struck a flame in me and then i
got the girl down there
you know that said she would come and
got her in the club his girl took her to
the club
and she started making money not as much
as his girl was making but the money
started being made and from there
i was able to see you know what really
basically managing the
girl you know what i'm saying in the
club you know i'm saying could really
the profits you could bring
and once i seen that it was on from
there to try to expand the business and
get more people
for it to grow and to get more money so
that's what i did and i was in memphis
tennessee
how did you grow up you you had both
your parents yeah i grew up my parents
but i just you know they was never
married
but yeah mom and dad around yeah mom and
dad yeah well
different times i live with mom and i
live with dad but between the boat
i stayed mostly with either one of them
mother how how would you describe your
childhood
it was cool i just you know it was it
was it was hard but it was love
you know so i like i said either way or
anything i went with a grandmother my
mother's mother had money
and her and her husband you know which
was my grandfather's step grandfather
they worked in general motors
i'm from flint michigan of course you
know general motors everywhere
there was a lot of that gm money around
so with them i lived a
fairly spoiled life but then when i went
to my father's mother
and went to the hood you know it was
like a three bedroom with like maybe
ten eight and anywhere from eight to
thirteen people living there at one time
all the time you know one bathroom
really a half of one downstairs work
every night then
you know but there's people on in the
basement laying on the couches
downstairs and us kids upstairs in the
bedroom you know plus grandma room so
it was um but like i said it was it was
hard you know but it was love so
with the love it was fun you know we you
know they made it you know you you
didn't
notice the struggle and recognize what
you know what it was because
it was love so you got started in the
game at what age
which game
oh yeah yeah well like i said i call it
management but yeah same thing
at the beginning stages when i first
found it that's what the man you know
that told me that's what he was doing
he had a whole a whole different formula
but he worked through the dance clubs
how old were you at that time i was 25
going on 26. and how many girls did you
have in your
in your stable with mo at the peak uh
six
six yeah i was living in a half a
million dollar house
on um i live in a half a minute out of
the house
um five acres six bedrooms five and a
half baths
um yeah it was yeah six this is where
this was in uh tennessee in tennessee
yeah memphis memphis
yeah and you'd have sex with the girls
yeah well it depends on which one earned
that earned that critic
you know earned that at the time how
that how i worked you know how the game
went
you just don't jump off having sex with
a chick you know
ain't no you know ain't matrimony it's
macaroni you know so you really
when you're really doing it how i
started it you know me i wanted to
give what i gave to the streets and
hustling to the game that i had embarked
on
and i didn't want to be phony and fake
you know me trying to beat you know i
so i wanted to know exactly how the game
really went and to find out what
how it really posed to go so when i
found out how i was supposed to go i'd
be i wouldn't be breaking any rules
because i didn't really know how it got
i didn't have nobody teach me the game
i just heard my man long story short the
guy that taught me brought me down there
and that gave me the information
originally
within 45 to 60 days me and him had a
falling out and we didn't talk for years
you know so it just so happened i ended
up running into the bishop them
through snoop through knowing some
people that knew snoop and i went to see
snoop and then the bishop was there and
the story goes on but i didn't have a
teacher of the information
to really know i just had some examples
an uncle that was a pimp that was my
mama's brother
they tell me stories about him and i
used to see him when i was young but
he's so dope and did it so
i really had no nowhere to acquire the
actual information
of how the game is really supposed to go
being from flint michigan but when i
went to memphis is a town
where pimping is everywhere you know
pimping is like i always tell people
pimping in memphis like selling
insurance
you can go door-to-door with it
and so the arrangement is you keep all
the girls money the girl brings you all
the money
well i provide a unique service i mean
we talked about then or now
either way well the whole time it's
um now well a lot of times with the
clients that i have that's what the
company i got now
i'm i don't even have to be there you
know i've already trained people to know
how to go so they basically manage the
money do the depart they take care of
the deposits
they do all of everything they got to go
with the business i don't even have to
you know so
now i got but back then when i was you
know just finding out about the
everything and didn't know i initially
started out pimping
but then once i realized that you know i
was just dealing with clubs and these
clubs are legitimate
why shouldn't i be legitimate so then i
figured out the best way to be able to
take what i was doing and do it in a
legitimate fashion and figure out how to
do that
that was paying taxes having my bank
account having my statements doing all
the things that it took
you know doing everything it took the
report to the irs
and do everything properly so that way
my business can last and i can continue
to do it even if
i don't have a girl but i got a
legitimate business when i find the
right person that understands
and agree to the contracts and the terms
and the agreement that we do
then bam it's it's our everything can
fail i can continue to grow and move but
if not
and avoid prison time oh definitely to
avoid prison time yeah definitely true
what like i said i'm from flint though
so i came from hustling in the street so
it made me
no never no i've been a county jail but
you know i never know but
all everybody i know went to prison to
die on their way to prison so
you know with that being said you know i
was all with that was my thing of
escaping from leaving flint when i went
to memphis
and was moving i went to atlanta they
ended up in memphis but i was trying to
find i could say i'm originally from the
streets
the huffs and hustling then to the music
you know i took my own money and first
took myself to the studio from selling
crack
i took myself to the studio and paid for
my own studio time and my own beats
so i was like maybe 16 then 15 going on
16 years like me
at the end of this year like in the 15
going on the 16th yeah
drugs have been a part of your life in
the past oh just
hustling that's all i like you know
that's only where i met i had to i left
i lived in like i said my family
normally at my grandmother's house the
one on my father's side it was no it was
always no less than eight to 13 people
in the one in the you know three-bedroom
you know so i mean there's people around
doing everything as
uncles aunties they friends so i learned
about you know seeing people doing and
using drugs and
and how to make money off of drugs and
that it was you know a profitable thing
when i was very young you know
and i've kind of like really learned it
in my own household from my auntie
keeping my dope when i went to school
and having her friends come by
the whole time i think that she was
buying and smoking it just with her
check but i didn't know no better she
just said she had customers she helped
me move it
and the girls that worked for you they
were using or not
oh no no i never had girls and if i had
a girl to use i always could be like
once again
i came from the streets and i know i
know a dope thing to make a dope thing
move
so i never wanted to take the chance of
dealing with girls that was on drugs
because i always knew that
if if i if if i make a mistake then i
can then i
i i stand for but if somebody else make
a mistake and i brought them to stand
with me
then the mistake is still on me so i had
to find out a way to make what i did
mistake proof so to speak
so no i never dealt with any girls that
was that was on drugs and if they were
on drugs
um it wasn't condoned by me at all funny
story uh
when i was in memphis when i was pimping
i got three i had three girls
my three main chicks i got and i went
and bought three drug tests because i
found out that you can get a
get the same you know test as you get at
the probation office at
you know at walgreens or whatever so i
go and buy three of them
so now i'm threatening the girls that
i'm gonna give them drug tests
so these these are girls that have been
with me for a while when i was in
memphis
so my daddy stayed with me at this time
he got out of prison and stayed with me
so um when i got ready to get a girls i
gave one of them a drug test
when i gave her one drug test i told him
no drugs you know so when i gave him one
drug test she test positive for cocaine
and peel some kind of pills
you know what i'm saying so you know so
i had you know
had to deal with that situation and you
know addressed that whatever
but once i did it you know i had two
more realities left
and so my daddy was my daddy was there
to see you know the whole thing he kind
of jokes her so he said
he said go ahead get the other two the
other test and see what that looked like
and guess what i said forget them drugs
because i ain't thinking about it i
don't even want to see no more
you know so but but no i always you know
the whole time like i said because of
the the drugs and from flint and all
that growing up with it in my own house
it was always my thing was to try to get
far away from it when i did leaflet
the best way i can wait that's why when
i found pimping it was such a beautiful
thing because
it was a way for me to totally eliminate
the drugs
you know and and the only way that i
knew to make money and survive was
hustling
you know you know with drugs that's all
i had new you know selling cracks so
and we eating you know whatever other
look whatever thing came up that was
profitable but anyway
yeah the game the game i tell people all
the time the game saved me
you know gang saved me the bishop always
say
he said he didn't sing this game you
know ruined people
and he hasn't seen this game you know
change people's lives for the better
you know and i can truly say that i'm
one of the persons who this game really
changed my life for the better
you know in so many different ways so
you know and i have no regrets about
none of it
i'm thankful you know for the transition
from the streets of really
coming from a lot of drugs and
everything negative and
use of sea of food use a food kind of
mentality and beat everybody and get
over and steal and take and lying
you know it was just you know for me to
go from that to pimping it wasn't no big
deal because i was already you know
just a different kind of game and
another kind of money you know but once
i seen the kind of money that was
legitimately able to be acquired
with with the kind of with the
legitimacy of using clubs to be able to
get the money from all i had to do was
manage the people that was going into
the clubs
you know what i'm saying create my
business create my contracts and then
get
get a mutual understanding that was
profitable for the both and so that's
what i was able to do with some cpas and
some lawyers and
and you know the rest is history you got
the black f sitting in front of you
but uh what's your style of interacting
with the girls
i mean a lot a lot of the guys i've
talked to have been like they use
intimidation
no i don't know my i tell people all the
time
my honesty is my best policy that's what
i learned
i've learned by being able to be honest
with the girls tell them what's up front
tell them what it is tell them you know
what what's expected you know what's
you know all this you know all the
scenarios possible
before they actually instruct themselves
into you know the aspect of doing it
i give them every you know every good
and bad scenario i possibly can
so they can make a clear decision to be
able to see if there's something they
want to do or not want to do
i'm not tricking nobody into something
i'm not forcing somebody to do something
like
what i offer is a unique server that has
already changed women lives them their
kids
you know i've had girls that come down
from michigan and and signed up with the
company
and and their daughter was three years
old at the time
now the same girl is still with the
company her daughter is 14 years old
but at the time this was before the
flint water crisis and the water was bad
she lived in the area where the wear was
highly contaminated when i met her
so what if she was still staying there
with her daughter three four five years
later
and her daughter would have been
drinking that lead water now her
daughter got us all a student
played softball been been through all
kind of training from uh
man everything from just everything kids
could possibly do in the suburbs
this young girl has been able to
experience that life you know i'm saying
and by being raised by me as her father
you know so
my thing is to do a good thing you know
i did from flint with the drugs i did a
lot of bad so as i've seen
the profitability in bit in the in the
in the real
business aspect of doing what i was
doing instead of me you know like i said
i don't disrespect nobody is in the game
and how they do it because i came from
it
but but but my heart is in a totally
different place
because i was able to find out how to do
it legitimately
in a way that can be profitable for me
and the girls and don't
and children and they don't hurt nobody
or bring nobody pain or no hurt
and i've seen a lot of pain and hurt in
the game both of them you know so
my thing was to try to move away from it
so i was like i say the game changed my
life
for the better period made me a better
person
maybe don juan the bishop whatever i
call him the chairman
but he is one of my best friends for
real he showed me how to be a friend
how to be the man on cuss the man don't
litter
these are things i learned from him and
and took those things into my life
to be like that not just not from him
having the girls and his
what he did the man is a genuine friend
a honest person
from what i from all i've seen with my
own eyes now other people may have other
perspectives that's on them
but this guy right here is something he
to me he is who he say he is and i've
never seen anything different
and the things i've seen is things
people may not even know him for
but those just two things alone not
cussing and not
putting you know not even lettering him
throwing out the window he'll drop no
trash no way he don't do none of that
you know and he has more qualities so
you know
meeting the people that i met in it once
and i got to give all the players a
shout out especially my shy time players
you know all the p's in the shot and my
closest ones
one thing they taught me from coming
from flint and being a hustler
we was always in competition even though
the players at the players ball all the
players in the competition to win and be
the best player
but one thing i learned being with the
players and being with the bishop
is that we complement each other i never
got as many compliments from men
as i did when i met the players hey
player man nice suit nice shoes man nice
oh oh man you and your game looking good
man bam bam
bam they compliment you the whole time
celebrating with you
not not not downing you not hating on
you not you know
it's just a different feeling around
about being around a group of people
like that you know they're supportive
and that's in in in the same sequence
with you but on a positive level because
they they ain't jealous of you they
ain't mad at you or not they may want
what you got
but at the same time because but even
not having it they still know how to
congratulate you
and that's church for real
you want to maybe take off your glasses
all right come on
what uh what do you look for in a in a
woman when you're
looking for somebody to work for you a
flat stomach
a flat stomach ladies if you ain't got
your stomach flat
you want to be with the black half you
want to be a part of teen concept
a flat stomach is the essence of your
success
period it's the difference between you
can be ugly but with a flat stomach and
a nice round but you can buy booty and
titties
but you can't you you might get all that
sucked out of there but just come with
it ready that way it's gonna still look
natural and good
a flat stomach is very important to be a
member of team concept entertainment
services my company
and to be with the black health and
represent what i stand for
other than sex for money or the girls
sometimes getting into like you know
i don't have anything i don't have sex
for money going that's what i'm trying
to tell you this is what i brought i
provide a unique service
the service i provide is life skill and
managerial services
for only exotic dancers working in the
team concept meaning those
in sequence together focus on the same
and common goal and that common goal is
success
yeah but i don't there's no sex for
money so let's let's put the x on that
one with the black f
i don't have girls that have sex for
money even since the pandemic has been
bad
and we're out here right now in los
angeles california all the strip clubs
are closed down
well in texas the strip clubs will open
back up within eight to nine eight to
ten weeks
and girls have been dancing the whole
time and the whole state has been opened
up so i've been blessed my business
hasn't had to suffer but when the clubs
were closed
i couldn't make money because that's all
i got is girls to dance my companies
just only manage exotic dancers
so they're not leaving the club they're
not doing this they're not doing that
everything that happens
happens inside of the club nothing's
outside of the club
what is the core of temp and prostitute
relationship she looks at you as a
daddy figure or no we'll see it's not a
pimping
like once again it's not a it's a it's
it's a it's a manager client situation
is what i got
now when i pimped you of course yeah my
host called me daddy
you know but this is you talking over 20
plus years in the you know
her go you know i don't even because now
you know
as far as the game go i i see i when i
when i took the name to black health
honestly
i took a lot of pride in taking that
name but i had to stand on it
like i stood on pimping when i pimped i
did everything the right way i did it i
didn't break a rule in it
i never would have because i wanted to
do it the way it was supposed to go
so when i became the black f i had to
stand
on my game and what i did
the way that hugh hefner sort of stood
on his
and so i studied a lot of you know
studied a lot about him did research
and one thing he did he he always stayed
with what he believed in
back when he started in the late 60s 70s
whenever he started really starting i
had a little after dark show
but the sexual orientation of women and
exploitation of it
was really shunned shunned down you know
they look bad upon that
so he had the the head of the cia which
was j
edgar hoover every playboy magazine
excuse me magazine that came out every
single issue
he had the fbi agent assigned to go
through every page of the magazine and
read every word and make sure that
there's nothing that he did or said or
showed
that was incriminating this was every
issue and this was a white man
with a with a white you know cia
director j edgar hoover
this is a white man so you see if they
was doing that to him
what would they do to the black one
that's calling himself you know
patterning himself after him what would
i have to stand on so when i had that
information it let me know that i had to
really
be able to take whatever came at me once
i did it and really putting it out there
for business i had to be able to stand
on something
that couldn't be shaken or you know
cracked the bent or folded because i was
hiding behind something
so everything i did i did on the upfront
i got contracts i did this i got with
cpas i got with attorneys
talk with people in different places i
had people do research for me that was
in different industries
pertaining to that um and i just found
out the best way to really do it and
then i found out a way that was going to
help me going
the business help the girls and let
everybody live a prosperous and winning
life
you know i'm saying beside a lot of
times the the lack of you know
the p might come up but the girl don't
get nothing you know what i'm saying or
she get just something then when she's
gone there ain't no
nothing else left the game ain't nothing
for her to do or with this company
the girls can come and acquire the
information that they can make in the
club and dance
and then after that they term their
first term they can renew their term
have a second term
but after their terms they can go and
take the information and run with it and
make the money on their own
but they came somewhere and like went to
college to be able to learn how to do
this with structure stability
without drugs without alcoholism all
these things are monitored but being
able to learn how to really be a dancer
and not going there green searching and
looking around looking stupid
but going in there with experienced
girls and learn how to become an
experienced dancer
but make the big money instead of going
in there green wasting time drinking
doing pills letting somebody say take
this or do this or do that no
you go in there with people that's
already respected already know how it go
and they can help you avoid all the
pitfalls that any new dancer would
actually go in there and come
come in contact with so it's a
revolutionary system man so as you
i see as you insinuate different things
you know i understand them clearly
because i've truly
have did them all in the past but now
you know it's been so long since i've
done that i've been you know
even before i was recognized as the
black f i was already living the black
lifestyle with these girls and within
houses and
doing what i had been doing before tmz
or discovery channel or
i've been on discovery channel tmc tmz
on the talk suit with ryan seacrest
and on quest tv because they licensed
the discovery channel
uh episode over and licensed that over
today tv so i've been on four networks
without anything without them just
seeing me and throwing me on there you
know
or being a part of something that they
threw on there but it was so interesting
they couldn't deny it you know
you know as i represented and
represented it to the fullest
and loved it when i represented it but
right now
what i what i stand on and what i do is
is a revolutionary thing that has
evolved from me knowing the pimping to
doing something totally different
that's like i said it actually works for
the male and the female both
counterparts
actually can win in it because there's
no it's a it's a different kind of stand
on it and you basically give somebody
the strength you had
instead of taking from whatever
strengths they can give you you see i'm
saying my strength is passed on
so people people women are standing up
they're not afraid they're talking
they're looking men in the eyes
in different ways because they have to
look these men in the eyes in the club
to do business so i don't teach them to
look down and not look at me
you know what they teach them how to
look men in the eye and talk to them and
learn how to be assertive listeners and
different things like that the company
teaches but these are qualities you need
to be able to make money
in the dota entertainment industry in
the in strip clubs
particularly so when you were you were
tempting in what cities memphis i've
been well i've been in a lot of cities
but i
originally came from memphis when i was
you know with pimping because through
one thing about the strip clubs you can
steal pimp because you can have girls
because
every customer come in there wants some
[ __ ] so
with that being said you can easily you
know a girl can go in there and make
money dancing and doing dances
but it's a guy that's just in town for
the night with a room he want to take a
pretty girl to the room with him and he
willing to pay three 500 a thousand
depending on
what she asked for who she is what she
look like so you get you so you make the
money in the strip club dancing
and you might have you two three dates
lined up after the club
every day this first nut you know the
first hour the first nut
we know the nut come faster than an hour
we can get some money
what to which which are the girls that
you worked with has been your favorite
all the ones that made money the new
ones i remember them all my favorites
the ones that made the money the ones
that you know it never was a favorite if
they didn't make a money because a lot
of the ones that didn't make money or
just came through and
you know passed through i really don't
even remember them that you know
other than a flat stomach what what
personality traits does a girl need to
to do this kind of this line of work she
just got to believe in herself
that's what i mean everything is
believing in yourself you can't you know
you can
you know or or have the ability to
listen to learn to believe in yourself
you know everything people you know even
girl hoes go out there they believe they
can go out there and get that money
you know the ones that's really getting
money they know it ain't no problem i'm
gonna go break these tricks i'm gonna go
get this money i'm gonna go find daddy
his money
i ain't got no problem with that matter
of fact let me go ahead get ready right
now
i'm on my i'm on my way yeah you're
gonna be happy tonight
you know that's what real hoes do you
know what i'm talking about with this in
the game
see what i'm saying so i understand it
clearly you know like i said i've had
some real hoes that i've
really they didn't come like that i
really trained them but like i said once
again when i was coming from flint
going to memphis i was more on my drug
dealer mentality i was
more on my you know real grimy hood
[ __ ] mentality you know what i'm saying
so i really didn't know the the position
of a player
and a true pi you know what i'm talking
about that was really supposed to carry
yourself in
in the likeness of a gentleman at all
time so once i got with the
with the game then i learned that you
know i let a lot of those traits and
ways go but it took me a while
i still had a lot of my flint that had
been on me all my life with me
when i got to memphis so i really
trained girls a whole lot rougher and
because they was black
it was a lot harder to fight for them
than white girls so i had to really
train them with a little bit more of
you know a little bit thicker skin
thicker coat so to speak
and so on but i was already had a thick
real thick coat on me so it wasn't
nothing to pass that one down but then
when i learned you know start dealing
with you know
learn to turn into legitimate and start
dealing with white girls and learn and
watch how easy or
they can make the money without doing
anything and how the clubs can just work
for them
they'll have to go do dates outside of
the club and do if i did that i'll be
the richest one of the richest guys
alive
so if i was still pimping with white
girls my money would be to the ceiling
right now
matter of fact i just come in here and
just hide something in this big
warehouse as long as you can keep a
secret
but because i'm not pimping and i try to
get girls that's clean it's not on drugs
it's not alcoholics and keep them
steered in that same fashion
to hoard the whole time during their
doing their two-year agreement
then that's a job in itself because
there's so many distractions in the
strip club
from guys bringing drugs in alcohol
floating all day to music playing it's a
freaking party so how do you keep girls
clean from
going to work at a freaking party every
single day
not now now you see what i'm saying now
you see and then
being black and calling yourself the
black heft how much attention you're
going to draw to yourself
so how clean do i have to actually have
this thing to pull it off
i got to have this [ __ ] squeaky clean it
can't be a
got to keep dusting and cleaning and
looking under and vacuuming it
yeah because i have to stand on that and
you stay out of trouble
of course yeah because i did the right
thing you do the right thing the right
things happen
i i don't know i ain't stupid i come
from a righteous family
yeah well it's honesty man like i said i
i don't you know there's a thing about
i feel good to be able to tell the truth
so i don't mind talking i could talk
this to a girl's mother to a girl's
father
even though they may take it in some
type of way but i feel i'm not i don't
feel any type of way to express
the the truthfulness about my business
and what i do because if you ask me the
same thing oh yeah i mean
again the same question i'mma have the
same answer i don't have to lie
you see i'm saying it feels good and i
have to i had nothing to hide
and to be able to put it in people's
faces even because they're gonna think
that it's something
that shouldn't that's to be bad but when
they speak to me and really see what i
do and see the services i provide and
how i have changed people's lives
even if i don't bring a girl into this
industry there's going to be a girl
going into a strip club trying to make
money somewhere
every single day across this country
across this world
so i don't control that but if i can
take somebody that would go in there
where they could go in there and show
them how to do it the right way
how to make a better life for themselves
how to treat it as a business
instead of as just quote unquote going
somewhere to make a little money off me
and have some fun
you know and really be able to structure
and get their bank account together you
know give them structure
structured living to show them how to
live in a structured environment
and comfortable eating the right foods
drinking alkaline water i mean just all
there's so many different things that we
do
to keep ourselves fresh fresh and
youthful and to become better and not
worser you see girls in the game i've
seen it plenty of times
for a lot of times the chick be with a
guy you know yes you go
as the years go on you see her she
looked worser and worser
if you see any girl that you've ever
seen with me as the years go on
she looks better and better she went
from a young lady
to a woman to a grown woman to a
businesswoman
depending on the length that she stayed
with my company so these are the things
that i do
you know i'm talking about and i'm proud
to be able to do those things and i'm
not shameful
in any type of way because what i do is
the right thing i'm not stealing taking
lie and cheating like i say
i'm honest people already know exactly
what it is you know what i'm saying and
now the system is set up to work i'm not
the person managing the money the girl
makes the money she manages
she has access to me to do all the
things that comes with being a business
person so they know how to not just
take care of the money and run
themselves and manage it but they know
they see the operations of dealing with
banks and making deposits and doing this
with legitimate money with the money
that's not you ain't doing nothing wrong
to make the money just dancing
so i mean this is it's a totally
well-crafted system
that um like i said i put together with
not just me and my thinking
from past experience but with some real
you know professional
opinion you know you know put inside of
it and um
let's say we we've yet to even reach our
peak you know like i said that was just
everything i've done so far to me
was just practice the real game is about
to start now
all right like well thank you so much
for talking with me yeah very
interesting
pleasure's all mine
you